demain voici maintenant d'inviter des
cinq dernières minutes et s'est invitée
est une grande dame du cinéma et du
théâtre
ginette garcin bonjour on est ravis de
vous accueillir sur le plateau du 13
heures de france 2 pour une pièce que
vous avez écrit le clan des veuves qui
remporte il faut le dis à un vrai succès
populaire au théâtre des bouffes
parisiens à paris qu'est ce qui vous a
inspiré au départ pour écrire cette
pièce écouter j'étais en tournée avec
maria pacôme j'avais remplacé odette
l'or et puis un jour j'ai dit tiens j'ai
envie d'écrire quelque chose et puis
j'ai j'ai commencé à écrire et j'ai lu à
marjah les la première scène elle m'a
dit si tu continues comme ça je suis sûr
que tu vas aller très loin
et voilà ça c'est fait mais je les ai
écrites en tançant au départ à jackie
sardou
oui malgré votre ami absolue moi j'ai
connu jacky michel n'était pas encore en
août à l'enrayer
alors on va pas dévoiler toute
l'histoire mais tout commence en fait
lorsque le mari de rose qui est le
personnage que vous incarnez oui
disparaît on va bien sûr il ya beaucoup
de tristesse mais aussi des surprises
pas forcément bien venus d'ailleurs sont
des choses qui arrivent dans la vie je
crois que c'est pas si ça peut arriver
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de connotations
qui sont qui font partie de ma famille
et de mes amis je suis quelqu'un qui a
le don d'observation alors j'écoute je
regarde et puis tout d'un coup je me
suis mise à écrire j'ai dit aller
allons-y
oui tout simplement cette femme qui
adorait son mari son mari meurt elle se
distingue merveilleux il n'a jamais
trompé et tout d'un coup il s'aperçoit
que elle a été plus que cocu puisqu'il a
fait deux enfants
voilà alors justement ginette on va
regarder un extrait la pièce et le
moment crucial où ou rose apprend
qu'elle s'est trompée vous a fait deux
enfants
on ne vous êtes monstruosité mais
pourquoi vouloir me faire du mal je ne
vous ai rien fait ou pas m'obliger à
voir des images
saluant la mémoire de mon tel amour on
est une garce
pour l'élu
nous c'est la paternité de vos deux
enfants pour de l'argent je suppose du
chantage et bienvenue à l'épreuve
oui prouvez moi que fossat fonds sont à
mon mari elle s'appelle stellman comme
vous il les a retenus il ya 15 ans
lorsque la loi est passée alors au sujet
de la succession il va falloir compter
avec mes enfants
nous connaissons bien la maison du
touquet le partage ce franc 3 le compte
en banque et bloqué le coffre aussi
quelle organisation et comment avez vous
un vrai humaniste un homme de confiance
c'est le parrain de jal une de mes
filles partent et sortez faudra bien au
revoir
il voulait des enfants ils vous savez
stérile il ne vous a pas répudier il
faut vous rendre à l'évidence vous
vieillissez je connais votre aide nous
avons 25 ans de différence
rené pas chien se sache rattrape assez
vite repoussé les répliques pendant
qu'au regard de l'express pour là c'est
le moment du choc mais ce qu'il faut
dire c'est que c'est c'est un peu le
clan des veuves et des veufs joyeuse
parce que c'est très sympa cette pièce
vous êtes avec vos petits bouts mais
vous savez il ya des gens qui reviennent
parce que les gens rient tellement qu il
revienne pour pouvoir entendre ce qu'ils
n'ont pas entendu impression aussi vous
mettez vraiment en avant cette force que
peuvent avoir les femmes à surmonter les
épreuves mais c'est vrai regardez les
femmes qui sont elles arrivent toujours
même si elle ne retrouve pas un
compagnon elle arrive à se se motiver à
faire quelque chose les hommes c'est pas
possible
qui va leur faire la cuisine qui va leur
faire ceci donc il faut qu'il trouve
quelqu'un d'autre
d'ailleurs je le dis dans la pièce on
arrive je parle d'une année à moi qui
aie qui n'est plus de ce monde
jeudi je sais pas mais son mari il a
était inconsolable
inconsolable pendant trois semaines et
puis voilà il ya aussi quelque chose qui
est très jolie dans ce texte c'est
l'amitié et la force de l'amitié entre
les femmes
absolument mais ça existe et nous sommes
beaucoup plus nombreuses que vous ils
ont intérêt à faire attention
alors vous inviter à vous intéresser
bien sûr aux femmes dans ce texte mais
mon petit doigt me dit que vous
intéressait aussi beaucoup aux femmes
d'aujourd'hui parce que vous êtes en
train d'écrire une pièce avec votre
petite nièce absolument oui c'est vrai
j'ai écrit une pièce qui va être
d'ailleurs monté en
2008 oui parler par mes amis qui produit
et qui va regarder ça se bat bien sûr
des hommes a toujours bien sûr moi je
sais écrire pour les femmes moins bien
pour les moyens pour les hommes
enfin j'ai pas encore essayé ginette
garcin mercier en tout cas d'être venu
sur le saas et une 13e revers c'est un
vrai plaisir de vous recevoir c'est un
honneur que d'être 20 sur votre plateau
je rappelle le titre de votre pièce le
clan des veuves avec ginette garcin
louison robin et gladys cohen c'est au
théâtre des bouffes parisiens à paris
merci encore c'est la fin de ce journal
merci à vous de m'avoir suivi tout de
suite la météo complète de patrice
drevet 20h retrouver david pujadas
excellente après ville où on se retrouve
demain même lieu même heure